[Música]
bienvenidos al debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález
la detención del rapero español pablo
hasél cuyo nombre real es pablo
rivadulla ha desatado un debate sobre la
libertad de expresión en españa'
el argumento de las autoridades es muy
claro hazel a través de las letras de
sus canciones y de sus publicaciones en
twitter glorifica o enaltece el
terrorismo y también insulta a la
monarquía española sobre el tema se
pronunció el presidente del gobierno
español pedro sánchez escuchemos
española tiene una tarea pendiente que
es ampliar y mejorar la protección de la
libertad de expresión existe además un
amplio consenso dentro de la sociedad
española para amparar mejor la libertad
de expresión en línea con la regulación
que existe en otros países europeos y el
gobierno de españa ya ha manifestado que
va a mejorar la protección legal de la
libertad de expresión la democracia para
la libertad de manifestación la libertad
de expresión incluso la expresión de los
pensamientos más infames más absurdos
pero la democracia nunca
jamás ampara la violencia la violencia
es lo contrario de democracia
el artista fue capturado tras un
operativo policíaco en la universidad de
lleida en donde ya se él se había
atrincherado con varios de sus
simpatizantes para evitar cumplir su
condena en la cárcel la justicia emitió
un fallo y lo condenó a nueve meses de
prisión al tratarse de la cuarta condena
que le es impuesta los jueces ya
decretaron que debería ingresar a
prisión amnistía internacional criticó
esta sentencia la legislación es injusta
y la interpretación que hacen los
tribunales no es acorde al derecho
internacional y a lo que marque el
tribunal europeo derechos humanos no
sólo la legislación sino la
interpretación que hacen los tribunales
no es acorde al tribunal de derechos
humanos articulado pero dichos humanos
ha condenado tres veces a españa en los
últimos años diciéndole que no se puede
condenar a personas exclusivamente por
injurias a la corona ya lo decíamos en
sus letras hazel se refiere al rey
emérito a juan carlos primero como un
capo mafioso y un borracho tirano
también ha acusado a la policía de
torturar y de matar a
manifestantes y también a migrantes pero
el cantante se defiende y explica el
porqué de ese tipo de mensajes en sus
letras
cualquiera que lea los tweets por los
que he sido condenados a prisión igual
que las canciones puede comprobar que yo
estoy reflejando una realidad que estoy
contando hechos sobradamente probados
que incluso han aparecido reflejados
tanto en prensa estatal como
internacional así que literalmente se
están encarcelando por contar la
realidad la detención de hazel desató
una ola de indignación entre sus
seguidores y también entre los
ciudadanos que a través de las redes
sociales convocaron a varias marchas que
terminaron en enfrentamientos con las
policías de las diferentes ciudades con
daño al mobiliario urbano y también
algunas detenciones asimismo abrió
nuevamente ese debate en españa sobre la
libertad de expresión y las leyes que
protegen este derecho dentro de un
estado democrático para analizar este
tema hemos invitado a manuel gazapo él
es doctor en relaciones internacionales
también es experto en terrorismo y
director del observatorio internacional
de seguridad de españa también va a
estar con nosotros alberto gonzález
pulido asesor jurídico experto en
propiedad intelectual y también en
libertad de expresión es integrante del
instituto de arte contemporáneo de
españa y colaborador de la o
de la ong primos les recuerdo a todos
ustedes que pueden ser parte también de
este debate ustedes pueden ser parte de
esta conversación pueden dejar sus
preguntas y sus comentarios en las redes
sociales la recuerdo estamos en facebook
y también no se encuentran en instagram
y en twitter como arroba france24 y un
bajo ese y arroba santi lobo la etiqueta
para que dejen todos los comentarios es
numeral el debate efe 24 pues comenzamos
y comienzo entonces preguntándole a
manuel gazapo el primer invitado que
presente sobre este debate que queda
abierto allí en españa y que desde esta
orilla del atlántico tratamos de
entender y analizar siendo españa pues
es un referente en muchos casos para
américa latina allí en españa entonces
la libertad de expresión o el discurso
de odio destruir la honra de las
personas como está el debate como cree
usted que son las posiciones allí
bueno muchísimas gracias en primer lugar
por invitarnos es un placer estar aquí y
debatiendo y analizando la circunstancia
en la que está ahora mismo sumergida
españa y también otros países del viejo
continente de europa y el resto del
mundo en españa ahora mismo estamos
viviendo un momento de crisis por una
manera de mucho movimiento por la
detención de un músico de un rapero cuyo
normal autístico como ya anticipaba 6
pablo hasél creo que en españa como tal
luego lo debatiremos existe un estado de
derecho existe una constitución existen
unas leyes y existen unos mecanismos que
garantiza la libertad de expresión es
posible que españa tenga que hacer una
cierta labor de autocrítica para
garantizar en mayor medida la libertad
de expresión desde el punto de vista
artístico ahora no podemos decir que
españa no sea una democracia o que en
españa no exista libertad de expresión
porque como tal la realidad está ahí y
se a este sujeto se le ha encarcelado no
es tanto por las injurias a la corona
que también sino por otros delitos como
amenazas mucho más graves
o enaltecimiento del terrorismo haciendo
referencia a grupos turistas como
el grapo o al qaeda
y qué opina alberto gonzález allí
también en españa' libertad de expresión
o esto es un discurso de odio
simplemente y claramente un discurso de
odio
bueno santiago pues precisamente
una difícil pregunta la verdad no
tenemos en españa una situación de
crispación como bien comentado manuel
bastante importante en este tema
y que es difícil ver
españa sí
y estamos en una democracia en españa'
ampliamente mejorable
los residentes van a entrar antes
al inicio de la noticia españa la ciudad
denunciada en los últimos cuatro años
diría tres veces por carencias en la
libertad de expresión
pero coincido totalmente con manuel en
que los hace no se le juzga tanto por
las injurias a la corona sino porque
hace una serie de declaraciones y aparte
en sus letras también enaltece el
terrorismo como bien les hablaban de
diferentes grupos terroristas como un
grupo como eta o incluso de calidad y es
verdad que es una condena de nueve meses
que se suma a ciertas condenas
anteriores que al final determinan su
ingreso en petición
españa es un país con problemas de
libertad de expresión sí porque no se
trata sólo del valor base se trata del
tónica se trata de la insurgencia
se trata de humo de la mina se trata de
clemente bernard y otros artistas que
aún no teniendo penas de cárcel
antes bien problemas con la justicia por
haber mostrado diferentes discursos
artísticos y culturales que no tienen
por qué enaltecer el terrorismo sino
simplemente incomodar al status quo
sabemos que la corona en españa tiene
una importancia vital a nivel
constitucional incluso y por eso a veces
genera fricciones y conflictos con la
con el sector cultural y con el sector
de la libertad de expresión en nuestro
país si manuel en este caso ya lo
decíamos no es el primer artista con la
primera persona que es acusada de este
tipo de hechos tanto en su
representación artística como a través
de las redes sociales no es el primero
en españa que es acusado de enaltecer a
los grupos terroristas oa sus acciones y
también en hacer señalamientos a las
instituciones españolas oa políticos de
la escena de allí de este país o
integrantes de la casa real española es
el caso de hazel simplemente un punto de
quiebre y están tratando de darle
visibilidad para que sea como un ejemplo
aleccionador para los ciudadanos sobre
cómo pues hasta dónde puede llegar este
tipo de casos dentro de la justicia
española
pero la pregunta es interesante pero
tengo muy clara la respuesta no creo que
el estado español el estado de derecho
español tenga que aleccionar a la
población en ningún aspecto en ningún
sentido el estado español el reino de
españa es insisto un estado de derecho
un estado miembro en europea un estado
miembro de la otan y de otros muchos
organismos supranacionales
españa no tiene que aleccionar ni dar
ningún toque al textil de atención a
ninguna parte de la población
simplemente tiene que aplicar su código
legal nuestro código constitucional que
es el que el que nos rige y el que nos
permite convivir quizás hemos de
replantear hasta qué punto determinadas
expresiones artísticas pueden ser
susceptibles de ser interpretadas como
delito no estoy completamente de acuerdo
las democracias son siempre ampliamente
mejorable si existe un amplio margen de
mejora por decirlo en otras de otras
otra manera en otras palabras ahora
españa no está intentando aleccionar a
nadie ni meter miedo a ninguna parte de
la población más o menos reivindicativa
o que esté en contra las instituciones
simplemente se está aplicando el derecho
y el código legal tal y como está
constituido con mejor o menor acierto
pero por favor no demos a entender que
españa está actuando de manera indirecta
podemos entender que está actuando como
algún tipo de régimen que intenta
aleccionar por su amor eso es muy serio
y no deberíamos entender eso
de acuerdo a como han transcurrido los
hechos vemos y ya lo decíamos no es la
primera vez que este cantante este
rapero era acusado era llevada ante la
justicia a responder por por sus hechos
y ya en esta cuarta instancia pues los
jueces determinaron que definitivamente
ya era momento de que fuera a prisión ya
había respondido por estos cargos en el
pasado
simplemente viéndolo así es el
transcurso normal de la justicia no del
desarrollo de la justicia porque le
cuesta entonces a un sector de la
población española entender que la
justicia está actuando le pregunto
alberto
pues porque actúa con hazel y con una
parte de la población no actúa ese es el
problema el problema desde el activismo
social en españa y las organizaciones de
derechos humanos es que tenemos una
doble vara de medir
evidentemente pablo desde el caso del
pablo hasél tiene su gravedad
y de hecho creo que ha sido en cierto
modo bastante correcto su tratamiento
judicial
el tema es que claro se persigue a pablo
hasél
y se persiguen otros artistas con un
carácter identitario e ideológico
marcado y a otros no estamos hablando de
que hay un grupo de extrema derecha
campando a sus anchas por nuestro país y
profanando
diseminadas no se exclama totalmente
fascista que también con la ley en la
mano teniendo en cuenta la tipificación
del código penal actual también sería en
delito de exaltación del terrorismo
entonces claro no se trata tanto de que
pablo fácil tenga que salir de la cárcel
o que su procedimiento porque el proceso
judicial que le ha llevado a la prisión
sea inadecuado sino que ese mismo
proceso judicial no se ha aplicado a
otras personas oa otros colectivos su
opinión al respecto
hay aquí un desbalance para algunos si
se aplica estos procedimientos como dice
alberto para otros no ya lo decíamos
está simplemente la justicia actuando y
este es el cuarto escenario en el que ya
se les ha acusado y pues ya los jueces
determinaron que era necesario que
ingresara en prisión y cumplir una pena
allí recluido
si me ha parecido muy interesante y
acertada absolutamente acertada la
apreciación que alberto es cierto que en
españa como también hemos estado viendo
de un tiempo a esta parte en eeuu existe
un importante incremento de los
movimientos supremacistas vinculados a
la extrema derecha vinculados al
neonazismo al fascismo y al
etnonacionalismo no eso es un elemento
importante que tenemos que también
prestar mucha atención dentro del jardín
democrático europeo porque lo estamos
viendo también en francia en reino
unido- en alemania en polonia en hungría
estamos viendo un incremento muy pero
muy muy preocupante de la extrema
derecha o de partidos de medios de
comunicación de simpatizantes de este
tipo de grupos bélicos que evidentemente
también están haciendo soflamas en
medios de comunicación en redes sociales
y que también cometen graves actos de
vandalismo y que están interesados
también porque no en acabar en la senda
del terrorismo con lo cual desde el
punto de vista de la seguridad del
contraterrorismo no podemos ser vagos
debemos de ser preventivos y no
reactivos debemos anticiparnos es verdad
de la extrema derecha existe en españa'
ha existido siempre igual que existió
siempre en eeuu y en el resto europa
ahora por la polarización política por
el clima de crispación socioeconómica
sociocultural está teniendo también un
mayor impacto de la manera que lo está
teniendo a mí en la extrema izquierda
con lo cual españa tiene que ser lo
suficientemente madura lo
suficientemente activa como para moverse
anticiparse y empezar a aplicar los
diferentes mecanismos no solo policiales
o judiciales sino también sociales
económicos y culturales de debate para
evitar esto porque estos son malas
hierbas y permitirme que apunte esto son
malas hierbas ya que crecen en nuestro
jardín democrático y acaban afectando al
desarrollo de la vida normal de
cualquier ciudadano tanto la extrema
izquierda como la extrema derecha son
amenazas a nuestro estado de derecho y
eso es muy importante y eso es una
realidad que está sobre el terreno a día
de hoy
manuel retomando algunos de los apuntes
que usted hace en esta última respuesta
habla de la polarización la coyuntura en
la que se encuentra españa en este
momento tal vez en otro escenario este
tipo de acciones judiciales y estas
detenciones y este caso en particular de
pablo hasél no tendría tanta repercusión
si no estuviéramos en un grado de
descontento tan alto en españa' por el
tema de la pandemia la crisis económica
la polarización política los movimientos
independentistas cree usted que esos
también son ingredientes que ayudan a
que este caldo de cultivo se vea
alimentado
si estoy de acuerdo con su análisis no
podría decir la otra manera creo que
todos los factores suman creo que todo
elemento en una atmósfera en un planeta
en un espacio de estudio influye no hay
ningún elemento aislado la pandemia ha
influido mucho la crispación social
la incertidumbre sanitaria de
certidumbre económica que está dejando a
muchas familias en la calle
evidentemente hay muchos factores que al
final acaban haciendo que los la
sensación se caldeen en los que los que
las pasiones que tenemos dentro porque
de una manera tomen temperaturas muy
altas y eso derive en conflictos
sociales este problema
en relación al citado cantante pues
puede haberse sin uno sin ninguna duda
visto incrementado por todos estos
factores ahora las protestas no son
nuevas
existen en españa y quizás en otro
momento hubiesen tenido menos eco
mediático no obstante creo que
la atención que está recibiendo el
problema de pablo hasél está excediendo
en demasiada la importancia que tiene si
la gente verdaderamente atendiera a
estudiar de forma pausada y científica
el todo lo que tiene que ver con este
sujeto y las condenas que tiene
impuestas insisto creo que estamos
quizás estén dando una importancia
desproporcionada a este asunto que no
por ello innecesaria pero sí
desproporcionada
alberto allí en españa' paso a otro
punto importante de este debate y es un
punto inmenso tal vez ustedes ya lo han
debatido allí y lo han conversado varias
veces en españa y dentro de este jardín
democrático europeo el jardín
democrático español como lo ha nombrado
manuel la libertad de expresión tiene
límites puede tener límites muchos
sectores dicen que los límites los pone
la élite política dependiendo de hasta
qué punto o hasta dónde le puede
interesar que tenga unos límites cuál es
el análisis que usted hace al respecto
pues otra pregunta bastante complicada
de responder
para mí sí para mí la libertad expresión
tiene que tener
un límite y es la dignidad y el respeto
a los otros ciudadanos que viven en
nuestra unidad de democracia lo que pasa
es que como apuntaba antes manuel
vivimos una situación de crispación en
españa en la que ese respeto se ha
perdido también uno solamente provocada
por esta crisis una crisis que viene de
1.008 la situación sobre todo de los
jóvenes en españa es totalmente crítica
y desamparada no hay una identificación
instituciones del absoluto no hay un
reflejo social en las instituciones que
un ampare a la juventud de españa y
claro esa desafección hace que la más
mínima chispa provoque todo lo que está
pasando la libertad de expresión nunca
puede llevar a la violencia con un que
puede amparar la violencia
pero no lo justifico pero entiendo por
qué llega así porque evidentemente como
bien comentaba manuel
las protestas no son nuevas en españa
desde el año 2015 desde que entra en
vigor la llamada ley mordaza que es una
ley de seguridad ciudadana que no tiene
nada de seguridad
pues empiezan todas las protestas
empiezan las condenas de amnistía
internacionales y otro tipo
organizaciones entonces es un caldo de
cultivo para que este tipo de
situaciones surjan
tenemos que analizar la forma más
profunda cuáles son los motivos
políticos sociales e incluso económicos
que determinan este este ecosistema aún
tan kiel y cuáles pueden ser esta
noticia social cuál puede ser entonces
ese ecosistema alberto
pues básicamente porque lo que creo yo
como ciudadano español y creo que mucha
una gran parte de la ciudadanía española
cree es que
el estado no está actualizado o no no
refleja la realidad social que vive el
país la constitución es una constitución
de pasada a una de constitución que no
apaga nuevas realidades sociales nuevas
libertades sociales y no para tampoco la
capacidad que tiene la por ejemplo el
ámbito digital de desarrollar una nueva
forma de ciudadanía
eso lo que viene un poco a decir es que
uno de los primeros pasos para mejorar
la situación de españa es sin duda
reformar la constitución y proteger más
las libertades civiles pero también la
seguridad o sea siempre se ha intentado
poner en una balanza seguridad y
libertad individual no por el tema por
ejemplo de la fiscalización de los datos
personales y todo y todo lo que sabemos
sino por ejemplo no
qué tiene que ampararse hombre con la
cual sabrá más que yo de este tema
las medidas de contraterrorismo
evidentemente siempre amparan y siempre
protegen más la seguridad porque
precisamente es su función pero que lo
decía que habrá un equilibrio un
equilibrio que es muy difícil de lograr
y tiene que haber una voluntad política
primero para que ese equilibrio se
sostenga no y que haya precisamente una
una conciliación una intención de que
los políticos de precisamente de aunar
todas las las opiniones y sensaciones y
sentimientos que claro que dejen de lado
de la ciudadanía española claro alberto
manuel su opinión al respecto sobre este
tema de los límites de la libertad de
expresión allí en europa y bueno en este
caso en españa y las las motivaciones
que pueden tener los diferentes grupos
políticos o el gobierno de turno aquí en
españa para imponer este tipo de leyes
como la ley mordaza que ya vemos que ha
sido muy crítica a nivel internacional
si evidentemente las críticas existen y
si las críticas existen tendremos que
escucharlas como ciudadanos españoles y
hacer una autocrítica para ver cómo
podemos consensuar una serie de medidas
que permitan a españa bueno pues
adaptarse al contexto como veríamos
hablando en este interesante debate a
las nuevas circunstancias que tienen
mucho que ver con nuevos sentimientos
nuevas nuevas identidades nuevas
percepciones y la propia evolución del
país como como actor vivo al final cabo
un estado-nación no es algo que sea
constante y que no evolucione sino todo
lo contrario es un elemento un estado un
país es el elemento metamórfico que va
evolucionando y va pasando por
diferentes fases sin duda alguna será
necesario reflexionar sobre cuáles son
los límites de la libertad de expresión
pero teniendo una cosa muy clara la
libertad de expresión en ningún momento
puede amparar o respaldar expresiones
bélicas o que inciten a la violencia
contra un grupo de personas
un tipo de instituciones es decir el
límite está muy claro y el interés que
no podemos permitir la libertad de
expresión en ningún ámbito ya sea
periodístico o político o ciudadano o
artístico se acaban utilizando como
catalizador como trampolín como
autopista como vía como excusa para
insuflar el miedo o el caos en otro tipo
de agentes sociales hemos de ser muy
responsables con la libertad de
expresión porque también es eso no sólo
es un elemento fundamental de nuestra
constitución española sino también un
elemento esencial de los derechos
humanos y esa libertad de expresión
vamos a tener que reflexionar insisto
sobre ella vamos a tener que cuidarla
vamos a tener que quizás también ampliar
la hacerla más flexible hacerla más
adaptativa a las nuevas insisto a las
nuevas sensibilidades a las nuevas
percepciones a las nuevas demandas de la
sociedad sin lugar a dudas ahora
teniendo muy claro que en ningún momento
esa libertad de expresión puede amparar
justificar expresiones de violencia
mínimamente bélicas o que susciten
conflictos entre personas si permitimos
que eso ocurra estaremos tergiversando
el concepto claramente tan sagrado de la
libertad de expresión
manuel y precisamente el gobierno que
lidera pedro sánchez allí en españa- se
mostró abierto a revisar esta ley a
darle un vistazo y revisar y ver cómo se
puede actualizar de acuerdo al contexto
en el que está españa en este momento
esta revisión
muchos analistas allá en españa dicen
que llega tarde y que reacciona
simplemente a la presión de los
ciudadanos por los hechos recientes que
han tenido lugar en los últimos días
allí en españa particularmente en
cataluña y que el gobierno tiene claro
que no actuar puede generar una mala
imagen dentro de los españoles cuál es
el análisis que usted hace de ese de esa
apertura que ha mostrado el gobierno
bueno creo que la predisposición del
actual presidente del gobierno el señor
pedro sánchez es positiva y cualquier
presidente del gobierno del color
político que sea si tienen una
disposición al diálogo y a la apertura
pues bienvenidos sean
yo como ciudadano creo que siempre es
bueno que tengamos en la política
independientemente de qué es proyecto
ideológico esté al mando gente
aperturista a gente abierta en diálogo
es el presidente el gobierno como así se
ha mostrado ha mostrado dialogante y
dispuesto a reflexionar para amplificar
y hacer más flexibles los límites de
nuestro de nuestro código penal y de
nuestra constitución en lo que se
refiere a la libertad de expresión pues
bienvenido sea estoy de acuerdo
plenamente con él como con cualquier
otra figura que defienda eso ahora bien
españa llega tarde bueno es en españa
tenemos mucho a fustigar nos no españa
no llega tarde podría haber llegado
antes sí por supuesto ahora españa
avanza a un ritmo bastante positivo si
lo comparamos con otros países sino con
nuestra propia historia yo no voy a
comprarme con otros estados
de la geopolítica internacional españa
tiene suficientes retos sobre la mesa
tiene que atender a diferentes
circunstancias a diferentes cuestiones
desde hace décadas y creo que vamos poco
a poco podemos exigirnos más sin lugar a
dudas debemos hacerlo ahora debemos
lamentarnos debemos fustigarnos y
debemos pedir disculpas pues hasta
cierto punto estamos haciendo todo lo
que se puede y llegamos tarde no creo
que se todo se está haciendo a su debido
tiempo y si no en las formas más
correctas si vamos a destiempo
alberto su opinión al respecto sobre
este tema llega tarde españa a
replantear esta ley a darle un vistazo
yo creo que sí
[Música]
en esto pues tengo diferencias como en
duelo
porque es verdad que tenemos la forma de
ser como estado por así decirlo muy
particular porque quizás somos también
un país muy particular
la ley mordaza entra en vigor desde el
año 2015
hemos tenido tiempo
hemos tenido mucho tiempo para cambiar
la verdad que otra administración
diferente porque es el pp
que
el que no mueve esta ley pero de hecho
la reforma de la que habla pedro sánchez
una reforma que entiendo que es
beneficiosa para el país habla más de la
tipificación penal no tanto de la ley
mordaza
estamos hablando de 490 mil 578
y en claro llega tarde
yo creo que llega tarde porque es una
reacción del gobierno ante un problema
que se le viene encima por las
manifestaciones y por los problemas que
estamos teniendo de inseguridad
ciudadana por las revueltas que están se
están sucediendo por ciudades como
madrid barcelona bilbao y demás entonces
se le puede achacar evidentemente que
hayan llegado con un retraso esta
propuesta de hecho ha habido cierto
malestar porque parecía que era podemos
el que iba a iniciar y que iba a
presentar esta estas medidas de hecho
hay una iniciativa legislativa que se
presenta el 9 de noviembre presidente
para cambiar todo este panorama y bueno
esto ocurre porque básicamente hay
varias ciudades que han tenido muchos
problemas de seguridad ciudadanas a raíz
de estas manifestaciones
hemos tenido tiempo para cambiar esto
que no lo hemos hecho también porque la
voluntad política porque no hemos estado
en gobierno de coalición
y porque también comprendo que es
difícil porque hay otros aspectos que
hay que mejorar del país estamos en una
pandemia mundial también es solo
anterior y nario pero claro la expresión
también no es alberto y dentro de esa
posibilidad de debatir sobre esta ley
hacer las modificaciones que da otro
debate también muy profundo y complicado
y es si son necesarios estos castigos
penales dentro de los casos de libertad
de expresión es necesario llegar a estas
instancias es uno de los puntos que
quieren revisar cuál es su opinión
también es muy complejo responderás
es muy difícil las cosas como son porque
realmente las penas de prisión tienen
una función y que evidentemente tiene
que
en última instancia lo que se entiende
es que hay una función de reinsertar a
un río en la sociedad
claro cuando estamos dando penas de
prisión
sus formas como esta
realmente no sé si estamos añadiéndole
el fuego realmente que no significa que
justifique este tipo de manifestaciones
pero no creo que sea la
la estrategia más acertada evidentemente
hay otro tipo de penas que son penas de
multas siempre penas no o sanciones
administrativas que eso es otro tema
ha funcionado de hecho y otros casos
como el del hongo del dominio por
ejemplo que nos entra en la cárcel sino
que también hay una pena de multa con
una cuanto una cuantiosa suma aprobación
también se lo aplica al tónica los doce
miembros de la insurgencia y a otro tipo
de artistas no sí entonces realmente las
pegas de cárcel
yo personalmente creo que no son la
mejor estrategia
pero entiendo también que hay
determinados momentos en función también
del carácter público o de la dimensión
de la manifestación que se haga en el
que puedan estar amparada por el código
penal y que por tanto sean constitutivas
de acción
al respecto para ir cerrando el debate
por favor
bueno en primer lugar rápidamente estoy
de acuerdo con una cosa que decía
alberto si españa tuviera un gobierno de
coalición y cuando hablo de coalición no
me refiero sólo al gobierno de coalición
que tenemos ahora sino un poco el modelo
alemán donde los dos extremos
ideológicos supieran dialogar y
tuviéramos la madurez política y la
altura de miras suficiente como para
hacer un gobierno de estado y tener una
altura de medidas insisto y una
generosidad y una inteligencia mucho
mayor
posiblemente tendríamos un gobierno
mucho más plural mucho más generoso y
mucho más sensible para tomar el pulso a
la realidad social y de esa manera poder
adaptar nuestros códigos legales ahora
atendiendo a lo que me planteaban vamos
a ver si hay una persona que lo que está
a twitter 'no está escribiendo en
determinadas y reiteradas ocasiones es
que incita
asesinar a alguien que celebra que pueda
ponerse una bomba-lapa debajo del coche
de alguien o cosas similares yo es que
desgraciadamente personal y
profesionalmente no tengo nada que
argumentar en defensa de esa persona al
revés me merece muy poco interés es
decir creo que para eso está la ley para
eso están los expertos en el ámbito
penal en el ámbito judicial y si han
considerado que esta es la pena para
este sujeto que insisto no es ni mártir
ni villano como lo como lo hemos
titulado pero yo creo que eso es un
también un craso error desde el punto de
vista comunicativo y martín y villano es
un sujeto que se ha accedido en su
libertad de expresión y ha ofendido y ha
puesto de alguna manera en peligro
la percepción de seguridad de otras
personas y eso es muy peligroso y como
tal si tiene que ser castigado con penas
de cárcel pues así será igual que si yo
playa santiago también te amenazó a ti o
amenaza france24 yo acabaría en la
cárcel claro es entonces el código legal
es igual para todos me quedan pocos
segundos para cerrar el debate las
conclusiones por favor muy puntual
manuel
qué va a suceder qué elecciones va a
dejar este caso para españa es un caso
que está en desarrollo las
manifestaciones se están teniendo lugar
en este momento rápidamente sus
conclusiones tenemos que reflexionar
sobre el panorama artístico creo que es
fundamental el arte es un medio de
expresión esencial para cualquier
cultura para cualquier país y tenemos
que reflexionar cómo podemos digerir
afrontar mejor este tipo de situaciones
este tipo de contextos verá hasta qué
punto las penas de cárcel son adecuadas
o son el medio adecuado para reinsertar
este tipo de personas o para hacerlas
para hacerlas reflexionar y simplemente
por seguir avanzando con democracia
novedosa y con humildad
alberto sus conclusiones 20 segundos
pues muy poco que añadir a lo he dicho
manuel la verdad es que creo que
necesitamos madurar como sociedad como
democracia y poder amparar nuevas formas
de pensar protegían
nunca la violencia que no nos cueste
creerlo pues alberto gonzález pulido ya
manuel gazapo en españa muchas gracias
por habernos acompañado en el debate de
hoy a ustedes recuerde que pueden seguir
dejando sus comentarios sus preguntas y
opiniones gracias por habernos
acompañado y siga con la programación de
france 24
[Música]